[Musica]
quando si vede un'immagine come questa
oggi complici una serie di fattori ci
viene in mente il degrado ci viene in
mente il fumo le ciminiere
l'inquinamento errori del passato e non
al vero programmato meglio le
conseguenze dell'inquinamento e che
quando invece vediamo un immagine di
questo genere qua ci viene in mente il
progresso non server e nella vita di
tutti noi no tutti i giorni il vostro
whatsapp il vostro facebook il vostro
instagram è parcheggiato lì dentro
ma la riflessione che volevo farvi oggi
è che una volta
questo era il progresso
abbiamo tutti iniziato vivere meglio ci
spostavamo con facilità la bottiglietta
d'acqua era più leggera tutto alla
portata di tutti costi marginali che si
diminuivano e quindi rendevano
accessibili al largo consumo un sacco di
beni che prima erano per pochi
privilegiati
e allora la domanda che mi pongo io eh
ma non è che se non stiamo attenti un
domani
questo rappresenterà il degrado se oggi
qualcuno di voi butta giù a mare
stamattina molti di voi saranno lati in
spiaggia con i voli butta a mare una
bottiglietta quanto sta male quanto si
sente giudicato anche dall'opinione
pubblica ed è giusto ed è giusto che sia
così
quanti invece mandando una mail stanno
male o si sentono giudicati
dall'opinione pubblica
e da qui che mi è venuta un po
l'ispirazione di questo racconto che
voglio farvi oggi paio di mesi fa
cercavo una corrispondenza con con un
cliente os corollato troppo velocemente
lo schermo dell'iphone e mi sono
ritrovato in una mail che mi aveva
mandato nel 2011
pronta alla mia lettura di cui non me ne
faccio niente piena di loghi piena di
colori piena di immagini con un bel
l'allegato pesante anche di una
locandina di un evento di cui
praticamente tutti si sono dimenticati
in quegli istanti mi sono chiesto ma sta
mail dove c'è fisicamente dov'è che
problemi può generare questa me la
locazione fisica di questa mail allora
uno cerca in internet prima cosa da fare
è guardiana dove vengono cos'era e il
cloud e tutti conosciamo il cloud la
parola che ormai diventata molto confine
nonostante il mondo dell'internet da un
punto di vista tecnico sia molto pieno
di parole difficili da comprendere il
cloud ormai lo conosciamo tutti paghiamo
anche quasi tutti un abbonamento mensile
per poter lasciare in cloud ecco il
cloud non è la il cloud giu in questo
istante il cloud oggi consuma suolo
allora iniziato di fare un po di ricerca
cerca di capire che cosa succede
non si trova praticamente nulla ed è
giusto così perché è troppo giovane
questo problema perché non c'è ancora
questo problema certo da qualche mese si
inizia a guardare ad alcune cose legate
all'ambiente
rispetto alle meno report una mail
produce 19 grammi di co2
magari potrei produrne un po di meno di
mail ma a me interessa le mail vecchi e
non le e mail che sto generando oggi
cioè quelle passate ma che sono qua
nella tasca di tutti disponibili così
come il messaggio whatsapp così come la
foto istagram facebook eccetera
e allora iniziò a guardare un pochino
che mediamente una mail nel mondo pesa
un megabyte comprensibile
mediamente un megabyte io lavoro
principalmente con le aziende inizio a
preoccuparmi di capire ma di questo
quanto ha generato dalle aziende e in
europa
vedo che un'azienda un insieme di
aziende che hanno mediamente 100
dipendenti che lavorano mediamente 220
giorni l'anno
mandano 3,5 miliardi di mail al giorno
3,5 miliardi di mail ciascuna mediamente
da un megabyte dove stanno
quanto occupano pratico vabbè ma usciamo
dal mondo azienda e usciamo dal mondo
europa iniziato a preoccuparci di tutto
il mondo
quante mail privati cittadini chiunque
manda ogni giorno 300 no scusate 200 e
50 miliardi di mail al giorno 250
miliardi di megabyte al giorno che
vengono depositati da qualche parte e
che sono accessibili
quando vogliamo in qualsiasi momento e
noi paghiamo perché questo succeda
quanto occupano 250 miliardi di mail che
ogni giorno vengono mandate dove stanno
non sono una nuvola lo sappiamo dove
sono qua un metro cubo più o meno non
sono un tecnico quindi mi permetto
eventualmente di aver sbagliato di
qualche centimetro cubo più o meno un
cubo è come se noi ogni giorno
bellissimo un cubo di plastica silicio
oro e tutto quello che serve per fare un
server e lo buttassimo amare perché
dicono buttassimo amare perché di quelle
350 miliardi di mail mandato ogni giorno
circa l'ottanta per cento
non servono a niente non le abbiamo
neanche vanno in spam sono newsletter a
cui vi siete iscritti o vi hanno
inutilmente iscritto quindi noi pigliamo
ogni giorno un cubo e lo buttiamo a mare
e magari il 20 per cento lo usiamo e il
20 100 contorna ci cono ma un cubo di un
metro quadro boom come se buttassimo
ogni giorno per mandare una mail una
bottiglietta di plastica in acqua così
via mail bottigliette di plastica mail
bottiglietta di plastica ma la cosa più
interessante è che siccome noi paghiamo
per produrre questo cubo e viva dio c'è
un'economia giustamente ci sta
migliorando la vita questa cosa la mia
domanda mi sono posto un problema inizia
a fare un po di ricerca ma vi assicuro
che dati scientifici non ce ne sono è
molto difficile anche l'ultima
di quante servirà ucciso in italia vede
il 50 anni 80 ma non si sa non si sa
esattamente c'è deregolamentazione su
questo tema la mia domanda è ma sto cubo
quanto vale
quanta ricchezza sa produrre stock posto
m 60 milioni di euro all'anno un cubo di
un metodo c'è una buona approssimazione
non sono precisissimo proprio o meno uno
spazio un metro per un metro per un
metro dove possiamo buttare dentro i
nostri dati che ci serviranno non ci
serviranno di sole regioni serviranno
due su dieci crea un economia da 60
milioni all'anno
un metro e allora mi sono posto un
secondo problema ma se ho guardato solo
le mail
proviamo ad aggiungere i due social
network così giusto per farci un'idea
dello spazio che viene occupato e sto
parlando di consumo del suolo nulla di
più facebook e twitter per essere
semplici in un anno per sturare i dati
prodotti dalle mail da facebook e da
twitter ci serve una nave da crociera
250 x 70 x 30 ho messo nave da crociera
proprio perché l'ottanta per cento
naufraga va giù non ci serve più
ma allora faccio un passo avanti ancora
mai a livello mondo livello mondo per me
che non sono un tecnico diventa
estremamente difficile capire perché io
conosco il bite conosco il megabyte
conosco il gigabyte poi già all'inizio a
dire forse c'è il terabyte sì c'è il
terabyte
ovviamente il tema serve tutto per
riuscire a dare una minima
quantificazione di programma da profano
è e allora mi sono interrogato su quali
sono le unità di misura seguente e ho
anche scoperto che non sono ancora del
tutto accettate cioè c'è un dibattito
c'è qualcuno che dice che dopo il
terabyte c'è il petabyte
poi c'è lo z byte no prima c'è sì c'è lo
z by poi c'è l'ex a byte
poi c'è lo yacht a byte ma qualcuno non
è d'accordo e ripeto da profano da
cittadino normale si cerca in internet
non si trova la giusta unità di misura
nel mondo si producono nel 2020 una
stima 60 z byte di dati data sfera
facendo un minimo di calcolo ma
veramente un minimo di calcolo e ripeto
con un probabilmente grossa probabilità
di errore perché ci sono troppe
variabili da tenere in considerazione
se noi dovessimo continuare con questa
crescita di anno in anno a produrre dati
nel 2025 ci vorrebbe
ho dimenticato un pezzo che dire scusate
questo 60 questi 60 z veit sono largo
circa divisi in 40 per cento di dati
legati all'intrattenimento 20 per cento
di dati legati al mondo del lavoro e il
rimanente 40 per cento tutto il resto
qualsiasi cosa che può venire in mente
vi dicevo se continuiamo con questa
andatura di creazione di dati da ma è
dio salvi chi sta attenzionando quanto
inquinano in termini di consumo se
continuiamo così nel 2025
vasto sarà sostituita da un enorme
server alto 20 metri che copre tutta la
sua superficie 20 metri è più o meno tre
volte il muro dietro dietro di noi no
per capirci poco male
in tutto il mondo possiamo sacrificarla
una vasto nostra livello collettivo
copriamo ma allora io dico andiamo al
2030 e nel 2030 ce ne vorrebbe avrebbe
una superficie grande quanto venezia
così passo per la mia città e se
arriviamo al 2050 probabilmente ce ne
vuole una grande quanto roma da qui non
rende bene l'idea
venti metri di altezza poco male ci sono
i deserti non lo dite voi ci sarà lo
spazio benissimo qual è il vero problema
di tutto ciò al di là di quanti consumi
potrebbe generare alimentare una città
di questo genere alta 20 metri ha fatta
soltanto di server quello che vi dicevo
prima c'è un'economia che fa 60 milioni
al metro cubo
una follia perché ipotizzando che il
valore generato da un metro cubo di
capacità di magazzino di dati si diventi
un decimo di quello che oggi quindi
sei milioni all'anno nel 2050 questo è
il valore dell'economia dello stoccaggio
dei dati migliaia milioni
a me va benissimo così salto il pezzo
non attorno avanti 75 volte il pil
mondiale fra 75 volte il pil mondiale è
relativamente probabile che qualcuno si
accorga prima che qui c'è da fare
qualche intervento perché la conseguenza
prima sociale a livello macro è che si
crei ancora più disparità di ricchezza
ovviamente è anche di condizioni di vita
la seconda è che questo non può rimanere
un mercato appannaggio del privato e
quindi ci si potrebbe sicuramente
aspettare presto tardi un intervento
governativo peso a una tassa sui dati
per esempio allora io quello che cerco
di fare nella vita con con molti amici
colleghi e collaboratori e anche in un
contesto opara universitario e quello di
capire cosa succede nel mondo e cercare
di andare nelle aziende raccontarlo e
accompagnare le aziende a trasformarsi a
cambiarsi per anticipare un pochino
quello che sta succedendo allora la
domanda che mi pongo è su questo tema
qua che è nato così e poi abbiamo fatto
un pochino di ricerca nulla di più cos'è
che si può fare per curare quel 20 per
cento
una cosa banalissima così come spunto
voi firmate la vostra mail quando siete
a lavoro una mail firmata con un
loghetto pesa inizia a pesare tra i 200
kg baite i 400 kg contro i 34 kilobyte
di una mail senza niente sotto vuol dire
che cancellando faccio un esempio questo
pezzettino della vostra firma mail state
contribuendo a inquinare un centesimo in
meno due centesimi tra i centesimi in
meno per ogni mei che viene mandata e
come se vuoi ogni giorno aveste cento
bottigliette di plastica e le butta ste
tutte a mare oppure una bottiglietta di
plastica e la butta stia mare magari
nessuna sarebbe meglio ma una contro 100
inizia a fare la differenza ovviamente
stiamo agendo su quel 20 per cento sarà
anche compito di altri
capire come questa va benissimo
benissimo la nuova benissimo mi manda
una cara amica un articolo l'altro
pomeriggio le stavo raccontando cosa
sarei venuto qui a dirvi un articolo
tedesco che parla del lancio della
raccolta differenziata dei dati quindi
visto che tutti siamo ormai abituati a
fare la raccolta differenziata uno dei
modi con cui iniziare a differenziare
quello che è il dato che non ci servirà
mai e quello che invece è un dato
prezioso e quindi siamo sicuramente
disposti a pagare per poterlo mantenere
nel tempo farlo sopravvivere nel tempo e
questo avere dei per esempio cestini
differenziati magari con una velocità
con cui viene completamente eliminato
dall'eso spegnere il dato inutile
abbastanza rapida allora perché questo
perché potremmo provare questa volta
conoscendo un pochino il contesto a
evitare che quell'immagine della
fabbrica che inizialmente vi ho mostrato
sbiadita sbiadisca potremo evitare forse
sapendolo adesso che mandare una mail
non sia un reato in futuro o che ai
nostri figli sia concesso non ci sarà
più ma sia concesso di guardare un film
in streaming per più di hicks tempo al
giorno
allora prima che scoppino queste
conseguenze sociali il messaggio che
volevo lasciare io è arriverà questa
ondata perché arriverà c'è un problema
legato al consumo dei suoli c'è un
problema legato a quanti dati in maniera
spregiudicata oggi stiamo generando
grazie
[Applauso]